(audience cheering)
(applause)
- [Man] Those passengers
boarding to St. Louis,
maintenance is still
working on the aircraft.
Estimated time of departure, 2:40.
- I don't believe it.
What time is it now?
- [Man] Passengers going to
Cincinnati, you should be
boarding in about 10 minutes.
- Cincinnati beats St. Louis this time.
We're still fine. We're still fine.
That was an optimistic,
that was pretty good.
We'll see.
Mike, I'm a little bit hungry
- [Mike] Yeah.
- Even after the shake.
But I can fight. I need a coffee.
- [Mike] Ok. I'll do that right now.
- Yeah, that will get me through.
(slow, calm music)
♫ No control, no just pain all in it
♫ Feel like a tsunami,
there ain't no calm in this
♫ One day, dawg, we gonna
change all this shit
♫ We no different,
this song's see
♫ you don't go trippin'.
♫ Please don't hold your head low
♫ Pimp it, when you get hot
- [Driver] The Four Seasons,
right, gentlemen?
- [DRock] Yep.
- Uh oh, it's true.
(laughter)
- My Snapchat literally froze
on update for the last
several hours. We're late
to San Francisco.
We're in St. Louis,
it's not even San Francisco.
It's all fucked up.
(DRock laughs)
(inaudible man)
- Bro, you're the best and you get them.
Mike to know, so does DRock.
- [phone] Gary, I've been watching
your YouTube channel
now for about five hours
and I'm still not done.
- Dude, you know what's
better than five hours?
Eight hours.
(phone inaudible)
- Dude, I didn't catch what
you wanted. If you're
St. Louis or London
you're fucked.
So badly it's fucking crazy.
Sold out like I've never seen.
Pisses me off because I
want you to be there bad.
I know a lot of you are
getting out of work now
heading to Barnes and Nobles
and other local book stores
and sending in those receipts.
Thank you so much
so humbled by all the content.
It's Zhang's birthday, you know Zhang?
- [DRock] Yep.
- Thank You Economy came
out on March 8th too.
- [DRock] No.
- Yeah.
That's interesting if you think about it.
(slow, calm music)
- [Andy] I had the car ready to go
let me drive your Escalade (inaudible).
- It's a big ass car. I don't I've
been in a car this big.
- [DRock] Me neither.
Really cool.
- [Andy] Dude, that's like
a celebrity factor to that shit.
- For now. For now.
- [Andy] When I posted--
- People were like,
'What the fuck?'
- [Andy] I even fucking said,
you know you're ballin'
when you've got--
- And that's what it is right now.
- [Andy] Yeah.
Headed to the event.
Andy is here. Tell 'em!
- [Andy] Tell 'em going to rip
fucking people's faces off.
- Faces.
- [Andy] Off.
We had one at St. Louis airport but
were delayed and we missed it.
- How quick does it take--
- I don't even know what this
light is. Is this a new filter?
- Yeah, that's called the cops
are about to get us down here.
- Oh, that's even better.
(laughter)
Is that a new filter for real?
- No, I don't fucking know.
- Did you update your...
Did you update your Snapchat?
- [Andy] No.
- They had an update.
- [Andy] Today?
- The font's different.
- Yeah, just a couple hours ago.
- [Andy] Oh, okay,
I didn't do it.
- [Gary] Anyway, here's
what he wrote,
"After we met a couple months
ago, I ordered all your books.
"I've been reading them
simultaneously when time permits.
"The new #AskGaryVee
book was delivered today
"and though I'm
only 17 pages in,
"I can tell you that
this going to be huge.
"It blows away the other three."
- [Andy] That's awesome.
- Yeah.
- [Andy] That's saying
a lot to you.
- You know what, this has
a shot, you know this really is?
It's literally the three
books combined 2016.
- [Andy] Yeah, dude,
it's an update.
- That's literally what I wrote.
The three books are the things
on my mind over a period of time.
If you think about it
there's plenty of motiv--
You and I probably have
the best read on it, DRock
'cause we sat there for fucking
11 hours and did the audiobook.
I remember thinking
"Oh, here's Crush It! shit."
That's good because that
stuff really fucking works.
Guy Kawazaki's review,
do you know who guy is?
- [Andy] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- He's a big guy in
San Francisco tech.
He fuckin' put something on
Facebook Live saying
and he never curses.
He's a proper guy.
He's like "Look, bottom line,
this isn't on of those bullshit
"business books that's like
'be authentic and do it.'
"Of course, be authentic and do it.
"There's a ton of practical advice."
(truck engine running)
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Man 1] How are you?
- [Man 2] Gary, nice to see you.
- [Gary] Such a pleasure.
- [Andy] That's part of
the deal, right?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Man 3] Gary, it's an honor man.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
How are you?
- Been following you for a while.
Very well. Welcome to St. Louis.
- [Gary] Thank you so much.
Nice to meet you man. Thank you.
- [Andy] Check it out.
- [Gary] Love it. I love it.
- [Andy] This is my
business partner, Chris.
This is my business
partner for 17 years.
- [Chris] Thanks for
coming out, man.
- Yeah, man, real pleasure.
Thanks for having me, brother.
Sean, 'sup man?
- Good to see you.
- [Gary] How are you?
- Good. Things are freaking awesome.
- [Gary] Things are good.
- Gonna be fire tonight.
- It's gonna be fire tonight.
- Gary, how you doin'?
- What's up, man? How are you?
A pleasure. Thank you.
A real pleasure to meet you man.
Thank you.
(crowd murmuring)
- What up, Gary?
Nice to meet you, Gary.
- Steve Albert.
- Steve, real pleasure to meet you.
Real pleasure. Good to see you.
- [Andy] This is a good buddy
of mine Greg Harb.
- [Gary] Greg, such a pleasure.
Real nice to meet you.
How are you?
'Sup man?
- Jason.
- Jason, Gary.
- [Austin] Gary Vee,
you're the fucking man.
- Thank you brother.
- [Austin] Dude, I love you.
- [Gary] I love you too man.
What's your name?
- Austin Evans.
- Austin, thank you for that man.
- Nice to meet you man.
- Real pleasure.
Thanks for coming tonight.
- [Andy] Dude, the funny
thing too is we gave
everybody drinks
beforehand so it's interesting.
Let's go in here and chill out.
- Beautiful set up, man.
Beautiful. Love it.
This was my favorite.
I got to take a picture with this.
This was my favorite Beckett
of all time. I made so much
money this day.
This is my favorite Beckett of
all time. This was the 90 score
Bo Jackson. I ripped off
everybody in seventh and
eighth grade, loaded up
and then made bank.
- Look at you guys.
Handsome mother fuckers.
-DRock, I know you're
asking me how I feeling
cause you're trying to make
some DailyVee 21 content.
-[DRock] Uh.
- I'm feeling phenomenal.
You got to always pay
attention to the filters.
We got the filter up.
- Oh shit.
- [Woman] Gary, stand next to
Andy I want to take a picture
like that with the filter
actually underneath it.
- How are we situated?
- [Woman] You on the right,
Andy on the left.
- I'm trying to do the filter
thing. Hold on. Let me see.
- [Woman] Holy shit. (laughs)
- That's hilarious.
- Mike, look at my filter.
I'm literally wearing the outfit.
- [Woman] That's incredible.
- That's fucking funny.
- [Gary] I didn't even know.
That's fucking crazy.
- Alright so this will be the book.
- [Woman] One, two, three.
Okay, let me take one more.
- That's so funny.
- [Woman] One, two, three.
- Oh, there he is.
- [Woman] Dude, that's golden.
- Holy shit, that is so unbelievable.
Liz, thank you so, so much.
Liz, thank you so much
for buying it at Barnes and Noble.
We're going to put you in
DailyVee 21 for doing it. Thank you.
- [Andy] So tell him what you do.
- [Sal] I'm a human beatboxer.
- [Andy] He's a professional beatboxer.
- Really?
- Yeah, I am.
- What's your name?
- Sal, S-A-L.
- [Andy] Shocking, right?
- Dude, that's amazing.
Can I get a little flavor?
Can I hear it?
- [Sal] Yeah, no problem.
- Let's do it.
- Okay. It's all video? Okay.
(beatboxing)
- Amazing.
Amazing, brother. Amazing, brother.
That's such a talent. Good for you.
Alright, great, I'll take it for
a little bit. Thank you, brother.
Sup my man?
- What's going on, Gary?
- There's so much fucking
content being made right now.
There's just fucking content
on content on content.
No, I'm ready. I'm super ready. Let's go.
Sal, there's so much content.
- [Andy] You have no idea.
- [Gary] The most content.
Content.
(crowd noise)
(crowd cheers and applause)
- [Gary] Sup man?
- [Man 5] Gary Vee, what the fuck?
Man, yeah man.
- How are you?
(applause)
- [Andy] Without further adieu,
we're bringing my boy,
Mr. Gary V.
(crowd applause)
We could of been anywhere tonight.
That made me laugh.
Thank you so much for having me.
I’m super excited we're here.
So what I do for living is that I realize
95% of money and energy is wasted.
It’s wasted in tactics.
And it’s wasted in creating
a fake North Star.
Recalling the beginning of my talk.
It’s wasted in creating a fake
North Star of what success is
or not having the emotional
strength to decide what winning
is for yourself and letting somebody else
define what winning is.
Your girl. Your parents.
Somebody you look up to.
Please, please, please
understand there are very
basic things that need
to get done to win.
One, play your game.
Always be on the offense
for what matters to you.
And two, realize that if you
do not have a skill,
if you do not have skills you don’t
deserve to build a business.
You can’t just read about it.
You can’t just listen
to podcasts about it.
You can’t just be about it.
You gotta have fuckin' skills.
Have skills know what you want
to happen for yourself, nobody else.
How do people saw Rocky IV?
The Russian one?
Just raise your hands, I want to know.
Remember that part with Drago
before the fight he said
I’m doing this for myself.
Fuck you, Russia.
That shit. Be fucking Drago.
Do your shit for you, not what
everybody else wants you to do.
That, my friends, is how you win it life.
I’ve spent most of my 20s sitting
with 80 and 90-year-old people.
Constantly. I was very fucking weird.
In public I would roll up on
80-year-old people that look
like they might die before
the conversation was over.
Airplanes I wish switch seats
and sit with an old fucker
and I would fucking drill those
people and I would ask them
question after question after question.
And those old fuckers, strangers
people that fucking died
six weeks after I met them,
those people formed my life.
Because I looked at 50 to 100 people that
lived it and their shit was the same.
Let me say this to this crowd,
how you make your money is way
more important than
how much you make.
How you make your money is way more
important than how much you make.
When you’re 80 and your grandkids
and your kids are
talking about your life.
Doing what you wanted
to do instead of what
everyone else wanted you to
do is the number one thing.
It’s the number one thing.
And so many of us didn’t
have the strength at 15, 16, 17
to not do what’s a society or
our parents wanted us to do.
The cool thing is it’s never too late.
It just isn’t.
I made a video about
60-year-old entrepreneurs
that went quite viral for me
and the emails are flooding in
and it’s fucking crazy.
It just never too late.
Guys, it’s basic but it’s hard
and it takes work
and so I wish you nothing but success
and I really hope you understand
the practicality that my talk
was framed in because
way too many people
are wishing who they are
instead of realizing who they are.
Too many people in
this room are hoping
for something without
understanding that
they’re so much better to
be grounded in what it is
and then going all in on that.
I am completely convinced and I
watch it every day that you can
overshoot your ambition by
understanding who you are
and then just being patient.
That in a 15 year window
you are far more successful
than you run to the thing that
you’re not in a six-year window.
There is way too many stories of this.
You know them.
Don’t be one of those statistics.
It’s hard and the only way to win is to
put yourself in the best position to
succeed and finally, and
then let’s go to Q&amp;A,
complaining is some bitch shit.
(applause)
I need to get more serious
about this topic.
I literally never complain.
During Jet games but other than
that I literally never complain.
Complaining is literally the
biggest waste of good energy
you could ever imagine.
With all due respect,
and this is the truth,
nobody gives a fuck.
It’s just true.
And it’s honestly, just so you
know and I've spent a lot of time
with winners at this point,
complaining is the most obvious
tell of a non-winning player.
Just stop fucking complaining.
Cool. Thank you.
(audience applause)
Thank you, brother. Thank you.
- [Man 6] Still time for five?
- Yes, yes of course.
I thought we have
something in April in LA.
Find out I’m convinced we do.
And if not, we’ll do it.
- [Man 6] We're still cool for five?
- Yes.
- We'll be quick.
Hustling, you can do both.
You could you just are going to be
able to fuckin' go to the Cardinals game.
You know what I mean?
You know what I mean? Yeah.
- Can we get a selfie?
- Yeah.
Awesome. Wish you well.
No, I think this book is so good
that it’s in my best long-term interest
to get in to as many
people’s hands as possible.
- Legacy over currency.
- It's great, right? It's real.
Tell him I said what's up.
I'm looking forward to it.
Stay well.
- You asked for a gum and I bring it.
- Hey it was really nice meeting you man.
Yeah thanks man.
I wish well brother.
Stay well.
No, no, no, as a matter of fact
I know the mediation is about
to explode and I’m not
going to do that either.
I feel so happy with my shit
that I would never fuck with it.
You know? I’m just a
purebred kind of thing.
I got what I got. It's good shit.
- You just got good genetics.
I never smoked. I don’t like
to fuck with myself
especially the thing that
would scare me the most is
something in my brain
because I’m so happy with it.
You know? Real pleasure
yeah let’s do it.
- Perfect.
- Thank you.
- See you on the East Coast.
Like I work 18 hours,
I sleep the other six.
I think too many people,
if you don’t sleep you die.
It’s not super complicated.
I’m trying to win what I'm doing
while I’m awake but I’m not
trying to prove that I don’t sleep.
Sleep is fucking, I slept
11 hours the other day.
I was just catching up.
Yeah man sleep is fucking the jam.
- [Andy] I hate leaving
people in line like that.
- Well that's why I was
going I never do it.
I miss planes I never want
want to let anyone down.
- [Andy] I told Sal to tell them
all when we're done here--
- Yeah, fine. Listen if somebody waits
another fucking an hour,
I'll fucking do it.
Nope. Let’s do it.
- [Andy] What can we help you with?
I think we should just go around
and do specific questions and jam on it.
-[Man 7] 'Cause when they get on
a bicycle they don't stay fat long.
- My man you got it.
You got the right analogy.
Nobody did video blogging,
and then nobody did e-commerce
all the good shit comes
from nobody doing it. Got it?
You’re doing a good job with this.
You’re pounding it home all night.
You don’t need permission.
From who?
- From yourself is where you need it.
You guys are barking up
a secondary reason
I’m on the attack
on all this bullshit.
The reason you guys are looking
for permission is 'cause
you know some people are fakers.
That’s why. You’re stuck.
By the way, by the way,
I did at the highest levels.
I don’t want to be pundit.
I want to be an operator.
I don’t want to be in the
business of being GaryVee.
I want to build businesses.
And so that’s what you guys are
struggling with a different version.
But the truth is it doesn’t matter.
I've come to realize
I motivate people because
I was gifted with a DNA
and I shouldn't take
that away from them
because it helps them, too.
Love it. Thank you.
Who am I making it out to?
- Joseph.
You know this is the number
one thing that most people
never know about this shit.
They see these level up shit like hey buy
500 books and get to the duh, duh, duh
and they don’t realize
it’s just energy exchange
what we’re supposed
to be here for? Yeah.
Do you know to mean?
Like people don’t get it.
Yeah.
Who do my making it out to?
Tyler.
- Appreciate it.
Yeah man, good job
impressed me with your vibe.
- I appreciate all you do.
- Thanks man.
Who am I making out to?
- Jason.
You don’t have to make it out to
anybody I’m just trying
to sell it on eBay.
I’m just kidding, Chris.
Chris that’s what I
always say to people.
when they say. "Can you just sign?
I’m like, "eBay?"
They're like, "Yeah."
Thank you, brother, I appreciate it.
You’ll get a kick out of this.
You want me to make it out to?
C-Y-L-E?
- C-Y-L-E.
Get back to the AFC
championship game until '98.
16 years later.
To Denver which was a heartbreaker.
Oh yeah?
2:36 in the morning,
4:30 wake-up call,
mission accomplished.